we are live welcome to the iron Lords
podcast episode number 61 and it's
another glorious Sunday we are back at
the roundtable on the Lord's Day
we've got Red Dead Redemption 2 news
state of decay previews Final Fantasy 7
remake God of War sales to discuss
so we're gonna get right into it so
let's introduce the Four Horsemen of
gaming you know you two suspects at the
roundtable my co-hosts with the co Mokes
my brother from another mother the
difficult game Conqueror and the ho of
the young wolf my main lord addict how
you doing sir what's going on you guys
don't expect too much for me of course
we have our most technical gaming Lord
the solo gamer who lives with a single
player selfish experience and also the
sastra nabis mr. offline profile
Illuminati himself mummy
Lord sovereign how are we doing sir like
HBO boxing Madrid
[Applause]
no dough and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the XS gamer
oh the Lord of combat sports was a man
of his convictions demands nothing less
than the premium experience and it's to
get money Jayma beloved Lord King how
you doing everybody in this room you
hurt me though let me tell you something
last night I watched Eddie Hearn the
snake oil salesman from the crust apart
to peddle his wares and you guys fell
for all that crap that Tony baby you and
David Haye was selling I knew it was
crap the first time they did it and it
was crap the second time you did this
because you put lipstick on a pig don't
make you beautiful yo let me tell you
about that fight turn David Haye had you
gas that we thought he was really gonna
get busy yeah we gay guys a glass chin
he got knocked out hey man listen he got
hit in ways first of all I have an
affinity for how men look but you are a
decent looking man well with a decent
looking frame and why the hell do you
have your father shorts on to mature he
look like baby halt found big Hawk
shorts that's how you got knocked out
your shorts was too big my homework from
credo and what's funny is the doodoo
from Creed told his family told his wife
yeah you can't come to the fight keep
the kids waiting to fight because it's a
fight and I might lose tonight it was
funny because at the end of the fight
he's like I'm sorry honey
[Laughter]
associated with HBO boxes Network okay
let's get this together let's this is
how it goes now you have triple G versus
unknown assailant all right and it's not
you bujji's fault
cuz Canelo fell the drug test cuz he got
busted using drugs yeah look I thought
the Canelo joint again educate me if I'm
wrong I thought he got hit with the
tainted meat and that's what it was not
listen I went back to the gym and it was
the dude that they had the slim fat
muscle before I left right I come back
this dude him and his girl look like
yeah it was black eyes and his skin
because you anyway too bougie got just
fight with unknown assailant eight and
um HBO production what happened I know
in sailing they get knocked out in the
second round it was a totally farce of a
fight it was disgusting it was nothing
worth watching
when Showtime puts on fights there's
competitive fights that actually it can
go this way or that way these fighters
are actually building this toward
something greatness now triple G and in
HBO is running out of options now they
gotta fight these young lions
so they mix it in now he has to fight
these guys out there that's hungry and
chasing his title so it's gonna be some
disgusting foam and
next couple of fights this man might be
stretched out all over HBO show and just
tell me have my space
get in the ring one in the mess where I
don't know Streisand triple G okay so
yeah when that go down I'm in cuz you
got me on the arrow spend time on it so
other than a boxing was like how y'all
feel today go over and tired and sick of
course we had no demon engine himself
nor kognito spreading that realness in
the realm of IOP not telling you what
you want to hear but what you need to
hear so well it's been a rough week but
uh what I don't know what to plain let's
start with Lord addict night he's woken
up from combat sports what have you been
playing Lord Eddie we've been trying to
play this week nothing but Rainbow six
siege
Yosi you wanted some new content drop no
I just actually been playing they sent
me one time and then I Lord solve what
have we been playing this week in the
corner no God I'm so I've been working
hard working the only thing I did play a
little bit of is Donkey Kong on this
which country man beautiful game I want
to play like the first stage so I
haven't really gotten a taste of how
difficult the game is I know they say
it's in those games have always been
kind of a pain in the rear they don't
control like funky Kong where it's it's
considerably easier yeah so I just went
to the old-school mode playing calling
it Diddy so I'll see how difficult it is
but the game's beautiful looks nice on
the on the switch I only got to play in
handheld mode yeah already looks really
good beautiful yeah the only thing with
the switch is I think that lettering
though man squinting all the time
is a residue from a real game pulled it
off the Wii U eShop the Wii U eShop was
like I think it was like down there like
39 30 by 40 bucks you know the price is
that much on their games right but cuz
they were pushing this at 50 it
mysteriously disappeared God that said
you drinking on the blood of your
victims look whatever's been playing
this week first of all I like to give a
shout-out to bloody knuckles no we did
Infinity Blade knocks on man he's from
all wrong yeah I love the community I
love you know entertaining and having
fun with other podcasts I want y'all to
understand like if I'm not on your
podcast or you know Tom doesn't um it
prohibits me from from doing it because
I work nights guys but if you if you
wanna do a little daytime action yeah
I'm so in this so that's what I did
yesterday but what I've been playing
this week I've been playing God of War
let me give you my things on that but
I've been playing pub Jean with my man
death for the squad we've been coming in
number to chicken dinners has been hard
to find brother but God of War and my
opinion of the game is still that you
have to get past their excuse me that
it's not got a war to me
mmm-hmm but it's God of War and I say
this in a sense that it has the power it
has an action and sometimes the cane
animations where you kill the heart roll
you know what that excited you know it's
like he dies the same way you know
doesn't make it any less amazing when it
does happen it looks very hot the game
is very fast plays the game is beautiful
guys coming in because my boiler went
guys and um the guys came and did a
boiler and I had put ductless AC and
heat and throughout the whole house and
he was here and I was playing the game
and guys like Lord Christmas Mitch I go
hard
he says God and you don't control half
that game hard against God of War he
said he's gotta say you don't know close
yourself off from playing it praise god
bless you no place I'm out my opinion of
the game is it's shaping up to be how
Zelda was that year as a game of the
Year candidate because all arm is it's
all the little knots and stuff is the
bowls are tied it looks beautiful than
the it's Kratos everybody's Kratos is
not gonna be the same yeah because of
the management system of the clothing
and I love that aspect now because the
first hour it was confusing to me
because they don't give you a tutorial
on anything
there's tool that you play RPG you know
how to build it up find stuff like okay
but and that's the my only criticism
right now for the game and the camera
the camera can get wonky at times and
some enemies that get behind you and you
have untimely deaths for no reason I
hate when a game kills you not because
of your skill but because of their flaws
inherently in the game but you know um
if do I take it up from the 8th that I
gave it to a 9
yeah it's riding that hard not right now
pause some and the game is colorful
mm-hmm that's that's the most that I can
get a color palette is rich really
beautiful the HDR yes I gotta give it up
to Sony I mean they give you experiences
that make you remember this is a
bookmark in our time right now for yeah
I don't like yeah we hitting our stride
right now guys pop G and got war pretty
much say for me only thing is on
probably through a maximum planner a lot
of our destiny to crucible so I've been
prepping for the war mine Cheryl do you
crunches we had a good flash point on
that this floor yes I'm trying my little
iron banners on them in all this up
stuff with the 6 is on touched a little
bit of God war but it's like when my
schedule is very difficult when I come
home is obviously I'm a vampire like
most of the Lords here so it's I don't
like playing a story intense game when
I'm tired like yeah like I don't want to
disrespect God of War by planing that
way so it's like I'm trying to find the
right times to actually play it so
usually when I get home I play some
quick something to get the energy up
that's where the crucible is going on I
was getting a little pub geo shout out
the Winter Soldier sound a little monkey
punch sinisterly man we came close to a
dinner we came close man I think he's in
there too so he's trying out the new
Matt King the miramar play with kognito
like when you get a Cognito sight
Oh minja crap now play with them all the
time right though I don't know how the
hell you slipped in there was like match
when I was in the building like I said
sinister and addict had a good fun
argument remember that addict you know
you know those two legs out of control
rock you died ain't it so how's the new
map is a lot faster it to me it's a play
on axe it's obviously optimized way
better I I got a theory though I like
trees the tree the trees are sparse yeah
I think Loki's just easier to optimize
way of the design but I like it a lot
like it's really fun there's a lot of
things to do on the interior abilities
and stuff like that I'm just I'm still
learning only did like 100 yeah I know I
know but it's it's weird because it's
like it's a preview program game that
you got to download the test server on a
preview from its so wish like why is it
goodbye
like it's weird or whatever that's
neither here no there I'm gonna take a
picture of a game cold for game pass and
I'm gonna say it a couple of times
journalist cuz people join us as you
know we have progress on every topic I'm
just gonna reiterate that after this I'm
gonna tweet out a game passcode for
everybody that's watching for a 14-day
you know trial so y'all can get a chance
to play state of decay and place you
know so that's my gift to you guys I
really appreciate you guys always coming
through cuz a lot of you guys came to to
smash last night and that warmed my
heart now the Kings followers
you're shadaloo Sam yeah man I agree
with you to answer him I think that the
lack of vegetation to render me is that
the CPU isn't constrained so I agree
with the you know actually I've been
playing actually dusted off this which
I'm play switching Ron she does it off
and I started up Mosab I started up la
new are oh really the first time ever
planning it I've never forgotten I'm
gonna tell you right now I have never
seen facial animations like that before
like like yet I mean that back then it
was it was a revolution and then they
never really went back to it cuz it's
not that easy to do
yeah I was about to say because they've
never I've seen future iterations of
rockstar games or any games really like
I can see the characters enunciate their
words like to perfection and I was like
oh this is this is Loki lit I missed out
on that one I forgot what came out
around that time but I always heard good
things about it then it was like a good
little shop sale so I got that for the
cheap you know saying but um yes that's
pretty much what I've been rocking so we
gonna get into the whole last week's
bonus offer and the people would have
spoken to the question with news of a
previously console exclusive title from
your preferred platform is also
announced to go to PC does this
negatively affect your view of that
console the winner at 75% in a threeway
isle peephole dominated to victory was
that no it does not affect me as a
console gamer group coming in that
second at 20% was the yes it devalues
the console I own group and SuperShuttle
third place all groups master keV I know
that was you what do the Lord speak
about let's get let's get our Lord Lord
sweet heart today
what do you think about this mostly
oh he's really out but this has claimed
the rope has claimed you but um yeah
what did we do the rest of the law is
think about this I was going to go with
option three that makes sense even even
though it came with earthly the second
one why would you hate on somebody else
forget in the game that you already had
and you blaze and you it's fine
Lord Kratos going hard on you saw he
said this but you get Microsoft he said
you pimping out you know your your stuff
was it worth it
put it on these platforms devaluing you
cuz it's a hole Microsoft perceives
their platform completely different to
PlayStation PlayStation has to
absolutely has to differentiate
themselves from Microsoft Microsoft and
be willing anyway they don't even though
technically choice it creates identity
fantastic absolutely sony has this
identity now with the PlayStation now on
the roof crap just can't you that you
engage with them well easy Xbox whatever
you know surface tablet playing the
living room the bedroom
so do you want you to put your ones face
off we'll get into that with the god of
war sills got a war cells are fantastic
for a couple of days Bob but if you
think about how many Playstations are
out there then they're not that great
like um saying you put stuff in that
perspective it's like okay where the
rest of them fails back there we go
what's actually throughout this why
would what the funny thing about it is
people like using sales terminology
saying Xbox one only has thirty million
units it's like what if you compare yeah
you know everyone keeps saying they're
like thirty million
all I'm saying is a halo halo five
almost so ten so you take that into
consideration all the people always be
making fun of Xbox for 730 million they
sold the majority they sold to one third
of their entire installed base and less
and less go into that it's been the
arguments been thirty million for like a
year and a half Oh
obvious attic anywhere they're they're
run like 40 to 45 and that's 45 pushing
it but I do think there are 40 and but
uh you can't really blame people for
saying that it's not their fault
Microsoft don't have any numbers but at
the end of the day it's like you can't
just keep saying they only have 30
million like loss and nobody's got a
more like 40 million at this point I
mean those things I just want to ask you
real quick act like what about the
people who were saying like in the UM
cuz a poll was lit I mean people were
definitely chiming in what do you feel
that with the people that was saying
like y'all you know Xbox is devaluing I
don't mean an Xbox Nally you know
because it is Phil is still loving your
engagement thank you for purchasing in
the Microsoft Store
Oh elevator building I'm feeling better
now go when it comes to that it's like
look like there's a D value that Xbox
console yeah especially something like X
bar like halo 6 comes out or a PC will
be pretty sure it pretty much no it's
going to like ok say here an argument
and say that like it doesn't devalue the
console not the brand it does the
console but it only devalues it for
somebody who has the capability of
having both things you only have Xbox
that's the only playing here's the thing
though if you look at it from a
perspective of you know people being on
multiple podcast if you're exclusively
not on one podcast you devalue give them
multiple choices like it devalues it
doesn't brag but it does hurt the
console in general there's reason to
like why do you think Sony makes it so
apparent to put only on PlayStation eat
iams do they say that at e3 last year
only on PlayStation only on PlayStation
right because they only played it we
don't have a presence in the PC world
guarantee you they want a presence in
the PC world but they don't know how to
go about doing it because their PC brand
sucks they name hate anonymous with PC
then Amos anonymous would hold in the
corner by myself gaming
yeah I know what he's saying yeah well
his pain is true when I'm saying is also
right it's both sides of the coin right
child the Lord droppin facts he says
Sony still says neo is only on
PlayStation on their website even though
you can buy it on Steam because at the
end of the day I do believe that there's
console people and there's PC people
people say why don't ya an Xbox well if
your friends play on xbox there's very
very rare to have cross play to that
point so if you want to play Halo 6 if
you want to play it on fair terms
you're not buying that on on PC if you
have friends at night and let's be
honest like Lois always saying it's like
it's a pocket of people that's gonna own
both but most the majority we represent
this minority let's be honest right look
at the Twitter and social speak the
majority of people you know they just
want something and they can just plug in
and go get enough to know but isn't it
true when you purchase it at the
Microsoft Store it's like a cross
purchase that comes on your Xbox as well
some games some Microsoft games like
resident evil 7 was yeah it's not all
all across the board but there's been
some select titles that have that region
if you're gonna push the windows
narrative and take away some of the the
appeal to having an xbox only for those
games at least fix the Windows Store
horrible and NAT has to be fixed because
again if that's the route everyone go
which is promoting this cross unity
between both platforms
that's the date day i'ma wear all my
chains and all my home
no boss boo but I think it's horrible on
purpose that you go over there like oh
yeah it is a 4k 60 frames but I gotta go
through the stupid story
I'm ago we had played in 4k 34 I just
slide it in like they need to have the
Xbox design people like this legit
recopy the Xbox one storm bring it over
bring it over you've gotta fix that
because I've been told by a lot of
people that they do not mess with that
at all right now we got to get that
together so that was the pole very
intense shout-out to everybody who
participated it was late we will have
the new one at the end of the show so
we're gonna get into these topics at the
roundtable Lord of sovereign cowboys
Indians listen if there's one game this
year there for me stupid switch include
mandatory switch tablets just to get on
your nerves the way he liked the the the
way he started that sins is how he
starts every damage you throw for the
switch you say well I wouldn't play this
on xbox I'll definitely play it on swing
oh we need to bring up more switch
topics that we don't we continue like
solve what's going on
title is decidedly not coming to supply
on killing people in the future gonna
have switch exploding on people
giving lowercase move a celebrated happy
born day care services birthday y'all
staying with the Lord today how you
doing what's up freaking know you guys
were alive I'd literally just got into
my room and I see no Lincoln oh my god
crab let me find you pretty good the
birthday boy how you doing man um man I
did something idiotic I went to work to
try to you know be a good citizen and
kind of help out a couple hours and now
it's like okay it's already the
afternoon and I ain't got nowhere to go
to eat so I figured but I should be like
on my way out and just a little bit
hopefully find something to eat eat some
cake or some ID and play some video
games but uh just another year you're
not I mean since me and my kids birthday
is like two weeks apart I blew all my
money on them you really meant left for
me so to show that I gotta say I was
talking about credos in God a war with
his little son no I wasn't talking about
Kratos my boy oh yeah I'm not talking
about Jada I was not saying him I wasn't
throwing those nickels
like a diss track no actually no no what
it is is I forgot that he was in the
joint doing that and no I was talking
about now I'll talk about not Kratos not
that great also my god of wool cradles
but he's like really mean to that kid
and I'm like that's kind of pissing me
off I'm talking about to be able to
transform their cradle okay doll just
one that'll give you the pole just
wanted to get you on that real quick on
the way you got you know how long we got
you but um
yeah basically did the three-way poor
about how like basically when Xbox or
games that are your favorite exclusive
kind of goes to PC how do you feel about
it and the people voted 75% it does not
affect them as a console gamer if the
game goes to PC so I know you've been
out then and Twitter streets fighting
that fight what do you feel about that
if that's how it's supposed to be if
you're a console gamer it's like it's
like whatever just like how you know
even with like motae plats who are like
marketing deals you're gonna play it on
a console that you own like you know I
mean like you guys you know Destiny's
got the marketing deal with PlayStation
but you guys are all pretty much my Xbox
you staying stop you from buying destiny
to you know what I mean so it's like
you're gonna play regardless you know as
far as like a lot uh it sucks because a
lot of this stuff it's really for fanboy
like it's bragging rights bullets in
point you need you need that come with
receipts you have like your lists you
need to have your meta scores you need
to have your MPD's to help you in these
senseless arguments that we have and
that's the only thing this is for you're
not I mean yes he is I'm gonna be fair I
got I got a clear fit about the
contingent that says you're not sure
you're you're showing is engagement
numbers cuz yeah lose it
when you saw a fight right you see the
two guys they fight and at the end it's
a as a draw let's say you draw it then
the fight and what god be like yo but I
landed more jabs though like how the guy
was like dude but I was a ring
generalship is how you see it I don't
care if PlayStation is winning I'm
winning on my xbox right I don't care if
our Xbox is losing because I'm winning
on my playstation wait whatever you are
engaged at at the moment do you really
give a damn who's wearing a constable it
doesn't put money in your pocket good
unless you getting a freaking paycheck
from one of these people you somebody
said Itachi's Metacritic scores for game
past they actually didn't a fan made a
did them a solid and put together other
meta scores for all the games in-game
pass and put him from best to worst for
them and Mikey Baro retweeted it that's
all yeah that wasn't done by Microsoft
that was done by a fan got it got it
that's what so so we got that out of the
way so lost solve we heard about this
read dead what's going on with this red
day can I go now yeah they released the
third trailer for Red Dead Redemption
this past week and I was hoping to get a
lot of like system stuff in this third
trailer right and what we got was more
story they you know we've gotten three
story trailers since we've seen anything
of this game so obviously they're very
proud of the story they're gonna tell in
this game but we're at the point now
we're a couple of months out from launch
people want to see the game if you want
to know what the game is um so I was a
little disappointing that little trailer
was fantastic um but what happened was a
the following day information started to
trickle out and we started finding out
that certain outlets actually had access
to a 45 minute demo
that they want didn't get to play two
days is what I'm Aegean first
gamespot like Germany or something like
that it was weird it's a really weird a
breakdown of different outlets oh ok
does it attack it's no fun talking about
his brand Iran we mean in the chat so we
got a breakdown of basically what the
world is and this was has me really
excited about this game basically I am
red dead to all of your actions matter
they have some sort of reaction to what
you do in the world in a way that isn't
pre-canned
um there's an honor system that there
wasn't the first one like obviously like
if you if you choose to be like a
big-time outlaw you constantly gonna be
in chase if you choose to do things on
on the better side of the law you're
gonna have less pushback from the from
the law um it just in terms of like how
you interact with people like you're
basically in a camp now right and
everybody in the camp has their own
duties to the camp right so if you do
your job well whatever it is hunting
cooking whatever everybody else in the
camp is gonna be the morale of the camp
is gonna be higher anything who's not to
the morale is gonna be lower and that's
gonna affect interactions with everybody
and that same principle applies to the
whole world like they were talking about
specific instance where um where Arthur
Morgan that this is the protagonist in
the second one when he's kind of riding
his horse too close to somebody's
property that he doesn't know the Duke
comes out and is like yo can you get
away from my property and so he doesn't
know how you're gonna react you don't
know how he's gonna react so you could
do a number of different things you can
point your gun at him and if he's
gangster he's gonna be like now I'm
gonna put my gun out to whole world that
gangster
Hugo running normal and you have to
chase him in court a cop right
the situations play out in such a way
the world feels alive in a way that the
first one didn't do the first one gave
you a big sense of atmosphere like when
you're out in the desert in the middle
of the night looking at the sunset like
wow like they really got it right in
terms of that but in terms of like how
people react to you there's only a set
number of like ways they're gonna react
to you like anybody you meet out in the
open world or whatnot besides stuff
that's on the story path um so I think
that's what's most interesting to me
about the game is that they're trying to
really create a living world like when
we look at you know rockstar games are
always an event and they always try to
bring something new to the table that
nobody's done no the thing about it with
this is now you've had we've had Zelda
and we've had two witcher 3 yeah since
GTA 5 so now it's a matter of what what
have they done to improve on those
things that we saw in those games to
make these open worlds even more alive
I'm super excited man again they're very
wise love with a wave this they're
really white gloves with their games and
they even beast here now like I've never
heard of them letting people like yeah
you can watch it for an hour but you
can't look look hiss boom did you get a
chance to see the red that trailer any
information on it I saw the trailer I
didn't see anything that he was talking
about I just saw like we didn't get to
see it that's the thing they they
allowed the outlets new see the tray see
the the gameplay and then report on it
but nobody has the footage for us to see
we haven't seen Jack like you could talk
about what you saw but that's it like
we're not giving you any footage so what
people have done in the three trailers
that they've shown they clip they told
them what parts of those trailers were
specifically gameplay name people had
spliced those together to show gameplay
that's as much as we got it was cool man
in the chat thank you so much man always
showing love
you're also jaidev's out to a cradles
remember he's got to give away the day
and I'm saying before you
nobody can show what I do
[Laughter]
are you any bit excited about our Red
Dead are you a Red Dead Guy like we're
you nope
also we do the same both of you I have
it I'm actually probably gonna play this
summer on the X in the same boat so I
didn't put the first one even and then
when it now see they've remastered on X
looks phenomenal I think I might have to
do that just to kind of be in a zone
shout-out to Jay man for making the
wrong decision and now he has to try to
find a ps3 to play right there and when
I he could have had an Xbox one asking
on Twitter he's like any would sell it a
ps3 I need to play red and I'm like
backwards-compatibility it might not be
a big thing to everything with our
perception it's a lord king red then are
you a fan of the first one you hate for
this no one will yet I thought the first
one was overblown two years late
listen oh how was never the dude that
liked in westerns doing one of that
photo so me jumping on horseback and
okay Corral me when grant comes out I'm
gonna get the game okay yo i'ma get the
game you know why i'ma get the game but
I've learned something new my new credo
is this I'm gonna get the game when it
comes out on game pass or something oh
when it comes free in a month because
purchasing game pass really you know I'm
not gonna front
I respect that when games come out you
actually you blaze the game all the way
to you your blaze in that plane you're
like I gotta get you outta here because
the new game is coming my is my stupid
stupidity am i stupid EDI buy a bunch of
games right I still got games in a
raffle that I'm trying to play I'm not
buying anything new What did he say
shame on the lot of yous facts Oh have a
multiplayer component yes the
multiplayer component game is coming out
now easier ruminate is that the battle
royal solve is that is that true what
battle royal I mean okay here pubs emo
down says I'll tell you right now in
front of everybody
no G mo day one
and you gotta remember they I mean
they're gonna do read it online and in
it and they're gonna improve on what GTA
online is so no Chris Chris plays that
GTA go angle front I'm not gonna front
Chris is probably the best GTA player
that I know he's selling cause for two
three million dollars currency anchorman
in the chat he started trouble he's sick
flip flopping like the Hulk and infinity
war because somebody expended the end
with a man like you ran will meet mill
bars the bars the garbage the only bars
no smoke only thinking David smoking the
tires when he burns out of the job I
don't know how long we got kids so I
want to get to the next up just to
Russia's and I really want to get kids
perspective on the next one if God don't
mind still ours don't mind but I read it
but we all read that yeah I was read
that out the moment the topic stop oh my
gosh moving along Lord King coming back
from our state of decay you listen all
right I'm so sick and tired of people
with these previews they got a chance to
play the game and it's talking about you
know the first thing with a Microsoft
game is they give you the complete
negative state of decay came out if
y'all didn't know they they came out as
a demo for certain people and they got a
chance to play the game a little bit
more in depth and they got a chance to
see the four
play aspect of it and people is
complaining that there's a rubber band
thing like when you go too far away from
the group right made a rubber band you
and pull you now might be an exploit
later on there might be a floor that
they have to fix when the game gets in a
while because conceptually the devs
thought no this is a good feature
because this is permadeath to your
character right people right you bring
your best character over heels wandering
off in your universe and you got deadly
grizzly bears this dead imaginable in
the corner come on now
imagine like like Lord King just like
falling and we're like a whole city away
and he just complaining the whole time
we're trying to drive you know this
works well for me because I have a dude
on my squad and um pug G death who likes
to slide off into the bushes
while everybody is over here fighting so
this keeps everybody close together
keeps everybody safe and warm and nice
and I don't really know you actually set
off everything with this a great tweet
this week and obviously you know we
heard the news that came out and tore us
out the Lauren you know there's some
people who valley are upset with the
fact that there's tethering that
progression is kind of locked in to get
that session of the host and then you
kind of put out a tweet that is actually
speaking to one of the game designers I
believe yeah from undead and kind of
getting the record straight so put it
out there kid what's going on what was
the feedback from that that whole
exchange well yeah the thing is because
I got really excited to get like these
guys on like a podcast for a minute
apologize for that so um the first thing
when I started reading these articles
the first thing I went into the ends of
like hey I started reading the press and
people were the crazy thing is people
are making videos based off to articles
yes um it sounds like all right let me
do this let me reach out to somebody I
know like that but that des sees
everything in in that I ass hey what was
the decision why did you guys do this is
that by choice by design fine I was
approved it wasn't like you know so
pretty much it was about like they had a
it was like a complex choice to make
that the technical realities were that
they were faced and meant that they
either needed to tether players together
or seriously damage the game in some
other way to avoid it we tested the
tether and found that it didn't hinder
what what people didn't hinder people
the way they feared and it meant we
didn't have to undercut the other things
that they that were good about the game
so we went for it look data Stan I can't
officiate kiss movie DMX
so we went for it as it was the best
solution to a problem with the downside
downsides in every direction um so it
was like it was a choice is the thing is
if they didn't have it
it would have impacted the game in
another way they would have went away
from the direction that they were trying
to go and they knew they also corrected
you know the stuff that games spot and
Eurogamer put out about the whole
progression system when in coop you it
is there you do progress you still
aren't the only thing you can't do it's
like the base you build with some on
somebody else's game or that obviously
that doesn't carry over with you it
doesn't like it's not gonna appear in
your world and the story mode like the
story missions that you do they don't
you're not doing it for your story and
they because they said they have a
dynamic story system meaning that the
missions we are gonna be playing static
a - there's no set mission order or
mission structure so when we all start
the game we all gonna be doing something
different even though we start to game
at the same time like you know it may be
the same location but it's all gonna be
different so there's a chance that a
mission I do in your game I may not even
do my game right that's what I'm hearing
so pretty much there's no there's no
linear separate progression and then is
also a bit of randomization or procedure
but far as the mission structure yes yes
so the thing is and then somebody tried
to expose that fact to say oh but when I
did it and this happened and they said
well your game we had like a preset demo
for you guys so he's always should have
that you know catch that - yeah I got
that it's like you know a lot of people
did this is how I feel about Xbox game
you guys gotta think about it think
about this think about it so I'm gonna
say this in the video and I'm probably
gonna say this on playing xbox right no
no you gotta think stay the k2
is being held to super high standards
for $30 but what he's the thing is think
why do you think that is and that's what
I'm gonna go into because I think we
just had the release of a certain big
bastard blip we had a release of a
big-ass triple a high-budget
quality quality from a from a franchise
that isn't new you know this it's got a
worry well familiar five years to make
took five years to make I mean this is a
big hitter you know a multiplayer
component oh my god teller and tour
shout out to Nate himself the anchorman
he said our cats had the written Far Cry
five have iPad and people wanted to give
back games ten to nine shout out the
Lord Iroquois disregarded the
multiplayer but the game was still worth
it even though it wasn't worth it worth
it to playing co-op because it had that
right but the thing is is that stay - K
- sure
I think it's unfair to try to say all
right sure God award was great well let
let's put that standard the God of War
Center on the next big Xbox exclude the
big I don't look at say the K 2 as the
next big Xbox exclusive look at as a
triple I he's like you know I mean it's
a triple I game man
Charlie I look at like come on if they
if they happen now now it's like hmm no
if they happen to one else some other
game whether it be a new IP or get
criticized the part right there though
he's saying it's because Microsoft may
release our big triple a bang in a long
time
what I care about is the fact that
anything that Microsoft do they're being
scrutinized by the kids that are afraid
you're afraid of what man you win it
stop being afraid that you will make you
oh you cuz you know you remember
you afraid it's the biggest autocorrect
that I've ever seen anything like you
press you don't have to even be looking
at the guy that you're trying to shoot
and you press that box but and then here
just fire arrow and save you're behind
like okay
it's nice it has flaws like everything
else but I don't hear nobody talking
about those flaws before the game came
out like this you come from
King you come from I want to get out of
Khan soon so my thing is this I mean I'm
gonna be really char like state of the K
is day one regard like if they
legitimately gave me the first one again
with a new can of paint I was in now
when the news came out with the coop I'm
not gonna go I was a little disappointed
not that Ted doing as much is the
progression now I understand that yes
you can trade out and you can do certain
things but it's like almost like you
know I'm coming in like I'm basically
not advancing my story at all if I shot
you got if you want to finish the game
while you're playing co-op you gotta
finish in one shot
well you've got it you're helping your
friend finish it like if you're come in
I'm in your game right and all the
progression is towards your game your
story my character he's leveling up
right doesn't advance my story and when
I go back to my game but my character if
he's still alive right that's my story
so you then lose your character in
somebody else's game
yeah that's funny though but that so
that's the thing is crazy cuz a lot of
people thinking like you know how much
treat this like it's any other game in
its day - Kay - from when I'm here is
not like an easy game like it let's
let's not all zombies like right risking
your character right and that's key
point kid you said because the
permadeath asked when I had this
conversation with Lauren we're going
back and forth for I understand these
concerns you know cuz he's really good
like he's like you know I'm only playing
single-player I'm not I'm not playing
co-op and I said look in any other game
I hear what you're coming from it would
be a detriment the only reason why I'm
not gonna set up giving at a past but
the only ones want to understand the
design choices like kids said because of
permadeath because if that person brings
their character into your game you lose
your character forever if he breaks
imagine this game I guarantee he's gonna
have like hard stuff towards the end
like the original one had breakout modes
imagine like your dude gets in the Xbox
like man help me with breakout level 15
I just need to do this one last thing as
I do I'll help you guy ain't taking the
main guy to take your main dude get your
main dude killed
oh now hard as he said the problem is
under less and their lab side will be
triple-a Xbox promoted it like it was
from the perspective of the original
game it's triple it's got three maps the
size of the original map
they build upon every panic in the game
I don't believe in the triple the double
layer any of that [ __ ] game it's a good
game regardless
the price is triple-a look at them mmm
look look at one of the one of the
biggest games it has ever existed
minecraft ending right right sometimes
it don't matter
like it doesn't some of the best the
game that's on PlayStation that people
loved when the ps4 first came out
triple-a some of the most memorable
games they're like you don't have very
often game a lot of the game is a
triple-a title alright the first game
was it was a shocker that it actually
hit you know got a cult following to it
and this game is anticipated for a large
crowd right I'm sick and tired of people
getting upset with who Microsoft chooses
to promote and who Microsoft chooses to
back and give those dollars to when you
trying to devalue Microsoft in the sense
that oh you didn't develop the game you
are promoting the game in such a manner
what the hell you want them to do oh
really like these games takes five to
six years to make so they're making
games in the background and Phil is sick
and tired of talking about game
that either has to get cancelled or
something happens so what we're gonna do
is talk about the games when they six or
seven months out so we can get a build
up from there we're not gonna talk about
games with a five six years out because
it's not working for us okay coming at
you Nick he said when Sean late and come
on at III stage win at infinity going
into all King David's animation for
stabbing people birthday zone not here
okay no it's gonna finish it finish this
up this whole thing with the state of
decay nonsense there's this effect a
tour day one anything the only way I
would cancel my pre-order if they send
me a review code respect you know
obviously the laws we went to packs you
know Lord Lord attic we all got a chance
to play ran fantastic I did not see any
glitches itself or like I did see any
that stuff as far as not we didn't in
our defense in their defense we didn't
get a chance to test out the coop in
any form we had like that yeah we had
the opportunity to we just didn't have
time but when I played it in a single
play I didn't experience any major
glitches not here and the actual detail
on the characters that's actually what
impressed me the most like you saw every
individual I don't like everything was
late the base build and all that kind of
stuff so every time you switch weapon to
show them putting it back and getting
the other one exactly you know saying
shut up letting the chat oh yeah so
again like I had no problems qualms with
the engine per se you know saying now as
far as a co-op yeah that's a little bit
of disappointing but it from from what
I'm hearing in South to just gonna just
put a great article it's way bigger that
spaced and even far crime and isn't
definitely not like an arc situation
like right next to you man you know kind
of thing so the vibe I'm getting as if
we're in a control space we can take the
house from different vantage points as
well as like as long as you're not you
know there's like a gas station like
right across the street you can go get
that but now if you're trying to French
her out way past on the map
you're gonna get that warning to be
teleported to where your man is that you
know kind of thing so that's where I'm I
saw you okay what it like I know you've
been kind of quiet I know if he was even
picking up stated again I didn't play it
on 360 though I didn't play it when it
was super broken I just play loose when
it was kind of broken on xbox what know
I love Stata decay and the tethering
listen man like we've had tethering in
multiplayer games halo had tethering
like you know it's one of those things
like that part doesn't bother me in the
least you know they're trying to develop
a certain type of game and if they feel
it's gonna break it by by letting people
just run around crazy then um the
progression stuff I think people might
when they talked about multiplayer for
this game people wanted to feel like you
were constantly you with your group you
were surviving with your group and this
was an ongoing thing where you you know
you guys you're all in the same can't be
helping each other out with resources
and stuff like that you're going out
together and it just feels like that
sort of breaks that immersion that
people really wanted from this game uh
we'll see we'll see how it works out you
know we'll see how it works out but the
gameplay is there the Syst
there I'm gonna have a whole lot of fun
with it it's just a matter of how far
those systems go um and if they do
anything to fix that because again I
think that's what people's expectation
of this game was when they first heard
about the coop stuff they're like oh man
like I'm have to cover my math back yeah
we can you know we can save and come
back to it and you know and it's just
it's not that so right hmm
no doubt so that's pretty much what it
is all right we gonna move on now keep
how long we got you got you for a bit
just a little bit some but I figured
waiting got you because I still got you
addict when that final fan but I want to
change up a little bit on the birthday
so obviously the bad award numbers have
come out 1 million days so tremendous
remorse Sony Santa Monica you know it
means so um you know it actually in
comparison we had zero dawn yeah
definitely clap for that that's amazing
um pretty much for us pretty much sold
2.6 in two weeks so ours is tremendous
success from this and what I want to
bring to the table today is obviously
we've seen the success we've seen gotta
work doing these numbers and the whole
narrative single player games is coming
back up right with him people say hey or
she sees single player it's the live you
know when everyone is kind of saying or
maybe even Phil was alluding to that's
saying he felt that you know Sinclair
was not then it be something right but
just in general like this whole notion
that it wasn't profitable we see these
kind of things and then I want to also
tie it into not like the the state of
Xbox but as far as where do you see the
future of single player games going is
this going to give companies more
confidence you know now to say hey we
can do this without maybe tacking on a
multi player and we can do that kind of
stuff so I got you good let me guess let
me get kidding Oh like what do you feel
about the you know the God of War
success and then single player games
move forward um man I don't think single
like the God of War success Bravo you
know I mean it desert but thing is I
think I don't know what podcast we were
in but all of us predicted like probably
two to three million in like its first
week right is that's impressive there's
nowhere there's nothing around that it
was that's great you know I mean there's
like it deserved it with all the
promotion that the game had the budget
had behind that game
and the commercial and critical
reception to the game it screamed like
hit so it was it was only right the
cells were to follow that with the
height that they had riding into that so
so that's cool I'm not surprised I'm
really not surprised but um as far as
single-player games I never thought
single players where games were dead and
they is the develop the publishers that
are out there they're not doing your job
putting them out they don't believe in
it because they keep seeing games like
pub G fortnight and all those come out
and that's bringing that continued
income when they they want to capitalize
on it and they can't really capitalize
that one single-player game so sure this
making money continued money from
single-player games isn't rare II isn't
there that idea is that if you have to
sell so many copies of those
single-player games to get that money
back especially with people like Game
Stop around that can we smell those
games can't really sell it once that's
something to consider and then you want
to think about like you know there's
ways to monetize single-player games
like how Assassin's Creed do it and all
this that's how far cry do it and stuff
like that whether it be through DLCs
add-ons
well they do with her right they can do
what they do with horizon they'll
release like some sort of expansion like
to bring high because they don't got
play if you notice after spider-man
that's it
that's it whether it is it doesn't be
real I like I like my single-player
games I like playing story mode games on
big multiplayer games so it's like we
need them I can't picture a generation
without those single-player experiences
and it's good that you know Sony is
still around Sony and Bethesda are
big one providing that I mean I
understand where the Activision's and
EA's are believe it or not I mean
they're they're just not really in the
position to the toil to put that out
well unless is they do these indie deals
with like the people that the boardroom
wants to know what's the next thing
smoking that's gonna keep these pockets
floating 3.5 million who you think makes
more money that a fortnight no is a fact
no yeah I hear you go on overall I guess
my question you is because of the
success like let's keep it a buck right
Sony is bucking the trend right they are
suing by doing these old uh did it
before it let's stop this is a misnomer
like this is the one off like oh my god
this ain't been tumbled so they did it
already
[ __ ] and of course of course and
horizon zero dawn and all I'm trying to
say is that it was thought that it
couldn't be done anymore in this kind of
market right that it wasn't gonna be
sustainable now we've seen it so the
question I got you looking is like do we
think now because of these kind of
successes that companies are gonna get
more confidence say you know what maybe
so you think this is that this is this
is kind of like the marketplace was
different when it was making a game they
had to keep continuing and with the game
so it's only gonna continue with the
narrative our single play experiences
sure yeah do they want that um that the
pub G type of game and no those games
that tell you something chat saying shot
going in because they like you know I
was nominated for games of the year has
been the single player games talk about
the Bethesda giant but go ahead
here's the thing when it comes to stuff
like that Sony never hit that goldmine
if they hit a gold mine like pop gee
that's multiplayer only they're gonna
start to convert all of these stuff
because they're like yo this game made
more money than God of War for horizon
and all the Uncharted combined
tell them and then they're gonna keep
trying like it looked look what happened
with Ubisoft Ubisoft had to go with
siege and then now they're trying to
redirect every game like siege Sony
ain't never ran into that Sony for the
most part that made solid single-player
experience experiences but they've never
had a goldmine in the multiplayer mark
and that's what really sells this I
wouldn't put it past in to try try to
bring in SOCOM wait for that if they
break back SOCOM guarantee you it's not
gonna look like old SOCOM it's gonna
bring me it's gonna be absolutely I
think God award creates a false sense of
security for other publishers it's a
trap because the thing is it's like oh
wow
single-player games are alive we can
sell it because not every node you can't
something solely
no you can't sell an eighth the way you
so got a war it has to be a ten salty
degrees with a with a DS and PlayStation
we'll never have to play banger from the
first party no idea what you guys saying
I don't want to diminish what you guys
say in reference because let's be honest
I mean got a war on so many levels
referring to the fact that they've never
went away from single web or one for
this track absolutely that's my excuse
for them is like that happen because
they but let's let them get a new dev
team that they make you know the the
rights to try something new a
multiplayer and then it become like
overwatch or something were there when
millions and every month over it Sony
has an immune to this unchartered loot
boxes was popping so they started doing
that [ __ ] with uncharted the multiplayer
now food you say and at definitely
which are saying for you know first god
what's wrong let's be with let's be real
like we gotta say this to like god of
War's from behind this risk not only was
it an established franchise that had a
set way of being played that completely
changed view the narrative the way like
that there's many things that could have
gone wrong right that could have made
that a disaster like could you imagine
like again
tell me sway like you know that's the
perfect storm but for the most part like
I hear with locating force moves more
where Kings going for it they sense that
you know that Jim we doesn't happen a
lot you know I mean will you completely
change the franchise you up end it right
so I can't to be honest with you in they
review franchises a decent amount but
I've never seen a franchise reboot
acquire like this game was back they
literally went switched they switched
[Applause]
yeah definitely so what do you feel now
because of all the stuff no Marcus off
is looking at this no like a spec based
on what's going they gotta make good
ones they can't they have to make
above-average story orientated games
because I said it from day one people
can say what they want people could say
what what review scores do review scores
would come out [ __ ] on a game it
could be completely biased that game is
fire and everyone and that game is good
we're just gonna sell your game before
any review game will know that's a
potential
what's gonna happen to dying light game
came out completely didn't no one
expected what happened and then it's so
10 plus million because if the game is
good people are gonna buy it shout the
salty green so he's on fire DJ he's
saying and I'm it's only to use their
party for multiplayer but it's not
acceptable for Xbox use their party for
single-player why is that Lord said that
that that's that's that's a double
standard and people like what third
party handled multiplayer dude there's
like five or six good Moe single-player
games that come out every year so don't
say that mode that you know it get the
single player can't be handled by the
multi might look at shadow of war what
what's that game that anchorman wouldn't
stop talking about those get on my
nerves which one gotta be a peasant yeah
it was definitely but does the game
Wolfenstein you got games and that's
just two games I named it the evil
within to those games came out in like
two months
just three mm-hmm talking about the rest
yeah
Lord normal I just want to ask you
before you head out to as well um as far
as now this transition is to Xbox and
wrap it up now as far as the the whole
rumors that with him hearing Nier
automata right could be coming with a
lot of these uh you know some of these
single-player games have been the
exclusively either was time that we're
finding out and now coming over to uh to
Xbox and obviously we're hearing rumors
of quantum break too right we hear
rumors possibly you know there's this
rumblings there's certain games that
what single play that might be coming to
to xbox what do you feel that they have
to really double down this year you know
I know we're doing like a pre III thing
and keep in mind kid you're muted again
in reference to Microsoft's response to
this like we know they're watching right
we know about the rooms with Nier
automata we know about the possible but
maybe a quantum break we're hearing
rumblings on you know the gaff and all
that you know so what do you think is
the response possibly with you know what
successes like a god war um well
remember they still working on a
response to horizon zero dawn mm with
the whole like you know the favorable
thing I think you know there's a room I
think um I don't know if any of this
stuff is gonna be realized at e3 um but
I don't even know if they have a really
a proper answer to God a war it depends
man all Microsoft can do if if crackdown
alright so state we got we got a decay
crackdown is probably gonna be a stuff
release in the next month or so right
and then you got likely force a game
that the best thing Microsoft could do
to really like give us a nice appetite
is buy out a third party exclusive or
something like that for a year they got
two games they could potentially do this
with which they probably didn't and
that's uh that inner cell and metro yeah
yeah by metro right new tomb raider did
not go in that route we talked about
shadow of the two radio a sixty news or
that audio cooled with the 1080 you know
for thicker or the first came out that
it was supposed to be full the dev must
have misspoke and you came out there
with 4k sixty so everybody went crazy
and I oh wow you know saying now it's
it's that either or it's a 4k thirty
mold or you got your performance AMOLED
with 1080 60 playing it on the X is
going to run the best
continued loss move like I said my piece
of related to that no I'm but I'm about
to get out of here
we got an Xbox in and IOP together man
for sure break big bring the day break
the date to the realm what is it a
teenth at 7:00 p.m. we're gonna be a
Friday yeah p.m. Lord King should be
around or sob you should be around at
you working but you're gonna be an and
the entire show is going to be about e3
for Microsoft for Microsoft know that
we're gonna set that off you know shout
out to the whole crew planned Xbox cool
mercs I cou you don't see Jess all along
so we're going to be definitely go
smooth enjoy your birthday man
can we just be cuz I'm going to tweet
out that Co fantasy topic this week and
you saying it man you go yeah that's
right I mean I'll just deliver gonna
take a minute I'm just gonna talk about
it 37 likes let's get to that part but
listen let me tell you something if you
don't follow me on Twitter I suggest you
stop following me right now I had King
David because I'm a king I want you to
do the the weird eyebrow thing you do
and say do it and follow me on Twitter
rap to someone last times I know addicts
not doing well everyone's got things I
gotta do today's gonna be a shorter one
well alright
Final Fantasy 7 remake so according to
some a game developer out there looks
like it's not coming anytime soon
they had paper where yeah they had a
company to a cyberconnect2
that was working on it and
looks like square took the game away
from them so they just don't like where
it's it's it's kind of going in the
direction it's going they don't like the
state that it's in our direction so
basically the way this insider was
saying he's like when has a company
taking work from another company ever
been a positive sign if things and yeah
it's not it's not looking good for uh
for this remix or this would bring it
real quick to the laws law solve and
Lord addict I know this was hard so it's
close to your heart what do you guys
feel about this is this the ever coming
out or you think you know I don't think
in that state I mean they promised it
they show they've shown trailers of it
uh I don't know you know it wasn't
gameplay everybody but that the whole
deal with splitting it up into multiple
and into multiple releases and make it
up making an episodic that's where they
went wrong like just you know condense
it make it the actual game do too much
make it pretty and I think people have
been happy it's like a niece and nephew
is playing with your switch and they
play with a wrong accomplish by making
it episodic I may understand like the
different the different world you go to
you can separate it that way but this
didn't make sense like if it was one
game before make it one game now I think
they think they kind of they overshot
wallet that was a blatant charge on your
card I'm going to close it with I know
this is close to us beer indeed or us
that's our heart like are you
disappointed or you just like way it no
I mean already didn't like the fact that
they went towards that like Final
Fantasy 15 thing I like 15 but at the
same time I didn't like 15 he I still
beat it I don't like the fact that this
was announced I mean look at Kingdom
Hearts 30 like Square Enix they don't
know what they're doing these days yeah
look they noun sticky noir say what
2012-13 yeah and we're 18 and it might
come out this year
Dana's Final Fantasy 7 remake what three
years ago and we have not even really
seen solid gameplay on the game we see
like clips but what I put told you shout
out the Dreamcast guy he he's been told
that all everything we saw scrapped it
all mmm
wow that's that's bad that's bad yeah
man I mean shout-out to him please
Final Fantasy stuff and chilling with
half-life 3 and Kingdom Hearts 3 wow
they're good yeah I'm a little saddened
by this news you know how I would
definitely come out but yeah this is ps5
kind of stuff to me so I think all right
so we're gonna close up sewers getting
this uh the pole and it's going on a new
one for this week a wrap so when
negative impressions or slash preview
coverage of a highly anticipated title
or released to the public before
released how much does this impact your
decision in buying the game a huge
impact will stop me from buying be no
impact if I love it
I'm still buying it see only if I'm on
the fence with the game or D oh it's d
this week okay can you just scared of
that Metacritic fan salute the law
school for coming through on his
birthday show in love in the realm of
the Lord that was much appreciated man
spent with the crew we love that the run
was very appreciative child the Attic
and everybody so we are hurting a little
bit rather getting through this show so
we're gonna get these um outros poppin
Lord addict what do you have cooking up
before you go I have a lot cookin up but
on energy to say I talked about
get some sleep I know you're not doing
well man thank you for coming through
Loic solve my man what you got going on
wicked if I will find you
I hopefully be able to play some God of
War this this week I got some Valkyries
to kill and that's about it that's and
you know where to find me and not find
me Lord can kill me today as usual the
jokes yeah bang bang getting everybody
all fired up about that little show you
was on it's not little but y'all really
need to go and follow and like and make
sure you subscribe to the smash podcast
death squad over there was 100% official
it gave me the outlet to talk about the
infinity war you know the and actually
to be honest with you we went in depth
and we had good conversation back and
forth it was just a really good podcast
we didn't even know we went three half
hours we we looked up and it was like I
said please check out the show yeah tell
me about your check out that smash
podcast you know bloody we gonna get you
on the show that's a fact think that is
their most watched podcasts or something
most like whatever we had engagement all
the way through for the teen half hours
shout out to those twelve people that
was really 100% all the way there we
have more viewers but it was like well
people that's so different three and a
half with us right all the way testable
to their podcast man oh I'm gonna go
play me some God war I'm loving the
progression of the game and I'm one of
those people that like to go in the
corners and find things so this game
allows you to exploration oh absolutely
it has the best aspects of like
old-school Zelda Metroid and the Tomb
Raider like that Rises but I love that
because every new thing you got in rise
of the Tomb Raider made your weapons
better made you
yet better and that's what this game
does so you just want to keep finding
stuff no no thank you say King the test
servers up don't do it if the king of
the test over listen Jeff knows for a
fact that I'm gonna be playing pub G so
you can catch me on
well you can't catch me on Instagram
that's not gonna happen all that oh I've
linked everything to my streaming I've
got that I've linked everything to my
streaming and I've been testing it right
now so I've been testing mixer I've been
texting twitch I've been going live
there mix it twitch and twitter in Paris
now so I'm trying to get the one that
has the Facebook and everything all
linked up so I can just like broadcast
hardcore at you guys but um listen we're
moving oh you know the whole build-up is
to e3 this shirts are in production give
you the colors we wouldn't give you when
they drop because we you're gonna
actually get them earlier this year like
I know last year you got them at the
right before the event it was able to
get it down but this time you're gonna
get it at least two three weeks earlier
because if you're going to eat three or
if you want to rep you three and you
want to be part of that hashtag that
tweet out and stuff like that to get all
that free stuff that's coming your way
you gotta have the shirt and you got to
be posting the shirt you got to be
showing with the shirt and I'm going to
tell who won the the PAX challenge
because uh it was six of you guys that
actually tweeted out the shirts way more
than that purchase two shirts so I
understand y'all want to keep it in the
wraps and I understand you want to let
everybody know you other podcast that
may seem like it's a rival we don't have
no rivals right there's no rightness we
have friends and we have family so at
any point in time you feel that we are
rival to you let me tell you something
we are not you could talk to us we will
come on your show you guys one right up
on you guys hit me up and don't write
proper people
it'll be is no rivalry man we love our
head you know we spend that realness in
the round you know how that go they shot
the BK yeah we're gonna be an e3 this
year you better be there VK Vestas out
you
you know I like you I got away you out
there and we put out that swagging tag
we're gonna be doing grilling we're
gonna be listen we are going to link up
with every last person that we really
messed with right we go show love facts
you tell me what I've been lately the
realness was spread in the round chat
was absolutely lit today thank you so
much you know I'm just gonna like I like
to subscribe get the audio up tonight
you get that our stuff to Chi by two in
the crew they'll get that poppin and I
was you know class point 14 whats up
with e boxes eve of the warm on if you
are interested it drops tuesday we break
their whole thing down is it gonna say
destiny probably not but it's hot y'all
it's actually pretty good
yeah you bought that experience in past
you gotta do it better because they
actually doing a good job and they
they're setting up for September which
is gonna be there taking King's tower
moment it looks like they're you know
stars might be aligned there so that's
pretty much what it is is gonna go up
sovereign is gonna give you all the
information on guys the pretty threat
hit me DM hit me up in chat hit me up
wherever mom I think us more than a lot
of other podcast like we this this is
what our primary thing right the show
and this is where we engage with all you
guys so we want to know what it is that
you guys want from us what more do you
want you want to get on the show one
what exactly we want to know what it is
that you guys would want in terms of
goals and rewards in a patreon because
at the end of the day it's about you
guys how much you guys engage with us
how much you guys care about the show
and the content and what we do so at the
end of the day it's it is about you guys
so please let me know hit me up on
Twitter here
eeehm hit any one of us I'll pass it
along to me absolutely yeah definitely
man because they go outside making a
point we definitely want to set these
tiers up right we want proper engagement
with you guys things that you want to do
in the gauntlet in the ring and the
gauntlet gloves go in the ring you
anchor one thing in particular that was
mentioned is was his Lord King getting a
tattoo of some kind of this logo right
here wait wait please be in a hammer
Kratos I will put all full-body paint
and I have my son dressed up Atrios made
it clear that he is willing to put life
on the line listen I'm having so much
fun I'm a fun do mom and if it's all in
the quest for fun get this done
absolutely so like I said hit up starve
hit us up with them as well like I said
just coming up trying to structure the
tiers get that thing finished off we're
gonna get this up as soon as possible
the road to eat wheat is coming got a
lot of good stuff planned it's gonna be
fun everybody enjoy this Sunday I gotta
go see infinity war for a second time
y'all are some new people who haven't
seen
so everyone enjoy your Sunday we're
doing up the realm was late bring the
Kleenex with you
[Laughter]